this morning
the if only you knew all right and this
afternoon
the man and his mission
i will lift up mine eyes and to the
hills from whence cometh my help
my help cometh from the lord which made
heaven and earth
he will not suffer thy foot to be moved
he that keepeth thee will not slumber
behold he
that keepeth israel shall neither
slumber
nor sleep the lord is thy keeper
the lord is thy shade upon thy right
hand
the sun shall not smite thee by day
nor the moon by night the lord shall
preserve thee from
all evil he shall preserve thy
soul the lord shall preserve thy going
out
and thy coming in from this time forth
and
even forevermore god is good
and all the time psalm 100 verse 5 for
the lord
is good his mercy
is everlasting and his truth
endureth to all generations and let me
say what i
frequently say truth endures
to all generations error will one day
come to an end
are you with me false teaching
false doctrine all forms of
error will one day come to an end
along with those who persist in living
their lives by error
but truth endures how long
forever the bible says in john 14 6
i am the way the truth and the life
jesus is truth deuteronomy 32 verse 4
a god of truth god is truth
first john chapter 5 verse 6 the holy
spirit
is truth to be a child of the heavenly
family
we must be people of truth and so
jesus tells us in john 4 24 god is a
spirit
and they that worship him must
this is non-negotiable you didn't hear
what i said
every weekend there are people
worshiping god in what they call the
spirit
but there's no truth but the spirit one
of the spirit's names
is the spirit of truth
and so jesus said in john 14 17 even the
spirit of truth
whom the world cannot receive because it
seeth him not neither knoweth him
in john 16 13 how be it when he the
spirit of truth is come if you have the
spirit
the only way to identify that spirit as
the correct spirit
is to make sure it is the spirit of
truth
not of tradition or of custom or of
habits
or convenience but the spirit of truth i
welcome you
i welcome the um is it bay
town la porte church family and the born
again
church family wherever you are thank you
for connecting with us and of course
the missouri city family where i am
wherever you are via facebook
or youtube however you're connecting
thank you very much
and may the lord bless your lives and
may god bless you again
for your interest in the truth when
jesus prayed to his father in john 17 he
said
in verse 17 sanctify them how
through thy truth thy word is truth
now sanctification is the will of god
first thessalonians
chapter 4 verse 3 and this is the will
of god
even your sanctification which is the
process of being spiritually cleansed
jesus tells the father here's how to do
it
through the truth
however sincerely you believe a lie it
cannot sanctify you
that's why god is looking for people who
will worship him in spirit
and in truth and in first corinthians 5
verse 8 let's keep the feasts in
sincerity
and in truth sincerely wrong is still
wrong
you need since as a matter of fact
without truth
sincerity is very dangerous
ah you didn't hear what i said you're
ready to sleep
without truth sincerity
is very dangerous
john 16 verse 2 jesus said the time will
come that they that kill you
will think he doeth god's service
millions have been killed in the name of
god but in the absence of truth
so much for that you look depressed so
let me leave that alone
is there anyone with us this evening
you're not a seventh-day adventist makes
your hand
you are not a seventh-day adventist
where's your hand
ah we have two nice people would you
kindly stand please
three or three please stand
all right yes let's start at the far
left my sister give us your name
shirley jordan sister shirley where are
you from
where trinidad does that include tobago
all right okay just checking just
checking just checking
the tobagonians may not be happy to hear
themselves left out
who invited you sister jordan
michael where's michael
dr michael ah yes my brother from this
morning all right
thank you very much for coming and when
i say god bless you immediately from my
heart
it's a prayer i offer with my eyes open
god
bless you you may be seated my good
brother what's your name
joseph that's the earthly father of
jesus how are you joseph
how are you good where are you from
that is antebego all right well it's
good to have you joseph
and did michael invite you as well
michael you're busy man god bless you
joseph thank you very much you may be
seated my good brother joseph
i spent some time in trinidad about nine
years ago just a weekend
i spoke at a youth conference my dear
sister what's your name
sister jordan what's the first name rhea
and you're invited by michael
all right real god bless you i mean it
from my heart god bless you say amen for
our friends
ah come on say it again one more time
god is good and all the time
how many of you love god can i see your
hand you love god
uh you know he loves you but god loves
to be told i love you
not just your spouse and your girlfriend
or somebody else's girlfriend
god loves to be told are you following
god loves to be told i love you so from
time to time during the day just say
father
i love you just tell him that and you'll
see the sky brighten as god smiles
i will jump to the message which is the
man and his mission what did i say
this side what was our subject this
morning too slow that side
too slow that side again if only you
why are you so slow you're so nice
looking why are you so slow you're
children of god you've got to be fast
what was our subject this morning
the ma if only you knew all right and
this afternoon
the man and his mission i'll ask you to
do three things one
preserve reverence are you with me
see a man for reference it's not very
popular but god
loves reverence so please wherever you
are preserve reverence you're watching
online
in your home preserve reverence your
location does not affect the holiness of
god
preserve reverence wherever the
president is
the the soldiers salute him wherever he
is at the white house
on vacation on the golf course they
salute him
he's the president god is the president
of the universe
let's give him reverence as we worship
him this is still the holy hours the sun
sets at 808
is not yet eight or eight favor number
two while i'm speaking pray for me and
say lord
put your words in that man's mouth
let me tell you something about
preachers
which you also share we have a carnal
nature
which loves attention is this mike
working
oh it is okay preachers have a carnal
nature which drives them to seek
attention
are you following me it has to be fought
with every day
you've got to take that carnal nature by
the throat with the help of the spirit
of god
and choke it into submission we have a
desire to speak our own words because we
think they sound good
but the words of a man cannot save you
these words will save you
all i'm saying to you with humility ask
god
to put his words in my mouth
if you do that you will benefit are you
listening to me
because i will speak god's words and
god's words will change your life
it will bring back your husband to the
church they will get your son
off crack they will do they will change
the attitude of your tyrannical
supervisor god's words that created
heaven and earth
can change the circumstances of your
life
ask god to put his words in my mouth
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9
then the lord put forth his hand and
touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words
in thy mouth divine words
in the mouth of someone made of dirt
what a miracle
and favor number three think
isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason
together as i said this morning
we serve a reasonable god
when cain killed abel god came down to
talk to him
when adam sinned god came down to talk
to him
when jonah was sulking because god did
not destroy nineveh
god came down to talk to him god is
willing
to talk to you discuss it with you
why are you angry he asking why are you
smoking dope he's asking somebody
why you keep falling down drunk every
weekend why do you need six and a half
wives why why why
he's willing to talk because he's a
reasonable god let's pray
our father in heaven we're grateful that
we can call you father
we thank you today god through the
humanity of christ
we are brothers of his and sisters
as we bow in your presence dear god your
holy presence forgive us where we have
heard
and misrepresented you calvary exists
that you might forgive you
love to forgive because micah 7 verse 18
says
he delighteth in mercy and the greatest
act of mercy is calvary
as i prepare to speak to your people
whom you love
in this building and to the other church
families connecting online and wherever
people are listening
speak through me to god please cleanse
my heart and give me your words to speak
suppress my carnal nature that your
glory becomes my number one priority
followed closely by the blessing of your
people again i pray for anyone who may
have contracted the coronavirus
in the name of jesus their god a name
you never refuse
in the name of that one who said let
there be light
in the name of the one who said i am the
resurrection and the life
in his name there god the name that
conquered death
hell sin the grave and satan in his name
heal anyone who has contracted that
virus heal the person god
i'm not asking for improvement father
i'm asking for healing
do it dear god please not because we
deserve it
but because you love to be merciful
now bless us with truth because truth
alone sanctifies
bless this country to god bless the
administrators
and every country represented by those
listening put them on the minds of the
leaders their god
this constant thought righteousness
exalteth the nation it also exalts the
individual who is righteous i commit
this service to your glory father in
jesus name i pray
let god's people say amen and amen
what's our subject
the man and his mission go with me to
matthew chapter 9 we'll read from verse
i'm reading from the king james version
of the bible matthew 9
reading from verse 10 it's uh
7 36 oh somebody corrected that thing
good
bless you for that i'll release you by 8
15.
i know you're itching to get home and
conduct bible classes and all sorts of
things
so i'll let you go as soon as i can what
book did i say
what chapter reading from one verse and
it came to pass
as jesus sat at meat in the house behold
many publicans and sinners came and sat
down with him
and his disciples and when the pharisees
saw it
they said unto his disciples why does
your master eat why eat with your master
republicans and sinners
but when jesus heard that he said unto
them they that behold
read with me now need not a physician
come on
but they that are sick but go ye and
learn what that mean if
i will have mercy and not sacrifice now
finish the verse
for i am not come to call the righteous
but sinners to repentance all right
read verse 13 again but go and learn
what that meaneth i will have
mercy and not sacrifice for i am not
come to call the righteous but
sinners to repentance now jesus on our
subject
is the man and his mission the man is
christ
jesus the mission he came
to call sinners
not the righteous meaning those who
think they're righteous
but really he came for the whole world
because there's none righteous
no not one but there's some people who
think they are
much to their they're shocked they'll
find out if they continue with that
attitude
that they're not righteous at all but i
want you to observe something
always read the bible microscopically
i am not come to call the righteous but
sinners but finish the verse to
repentance
in other words christ came to say stop
what you're doing of course i'll give
you the power to stop
christ came to say stop
what you're doing why because you're
killing yourself
go to matthew chapter four
matthew chapter four let's read verse
17.
do you have that read with me from that
time
jesus began to and to say
repent why what did jesus say
repent repent
let's go to mark chapter six
repent means turn away from what you're
doing that's offending god
it hurts god but it won't kill god he'll
hurt you and kill you
you miss what i said our sins if we
persist
they hurt us and will eventually kill us
our sins
hurt god but they do not kill god
yes jesus paid a price but he rose are
you following me
god will survive our sins we will not
are you with me all right what book did
i say mark
what chapter 6 read verse 12. what does
that say
and they went out and preached
that men should repent who told them to
preach that
jesus you read for seven he sent them
out two by two
jesus came to say repent
stop
he came not to call the righteous but
sinners he came to
call sinners the very people running
from christ
he came to call
our subject the man in this mission let
us go
to luke 19.
luke 19 we'll read from verse 1 so we
can read the bible a little bit we don't
read it enough
which is a great loss for those who
don't jesus said man shall not live by
bread alone but by every word that
proceedeth out of the mouth of god
and that's genesis to revelation and
it's all condensed into ten commandments
because that's the whole duty of man
you have luke 19 reading at verse 1
let's pray again father
as i continue remind me constantly that
i am here for your glory not mine
in jesus name i pray amen and jesus
entered and passed through jericho and
behold there was a man named zacchaeus
which was a chief among republicans and
he was
rich and he sought to see jesus who he
was
and could not for the press why because
he was
little of stature and he ran before and
climbed up into the sycamore tree
to see him for he was to do what passed
that way
and when jesus came to the place he
looked up and saw him
and said unto him what zacchaeus make
haste and come down
for today i must abide at thy house keep
reading verse 6 and he
made haste and came down and received
him joyfully
and when they saw it they all murmured
saying that he had gone to be guests
with a man that is
a sinner but did not we read jesus came
for the sinners
which means he came for you and for me
and zacchaeus said and said unto the
lord
behold lord the half of my goods i give
to the poor
and if i have taken anything from any
man by false accusation
i restore him fourfold by the way if
you've wronged someone
an apology may not be enough apology
must be backed up with restitution
if that is required you borrowed money
it's been 15 years you haven't paid it
sorry is not enough are you following me
if i have taken anything from any man by
false accusation
i restore him fourfold and jesus said
unto him
this day is salvation come into this
house
for as much as he also is a son of
abraham
now read verse 10 with me
for the son of man is come to seek
and to save that which was lost
seek save
the lost if you add
what we read sinister repentance
seek save by bringing the lost
to repentance by the way repentance is a
gift god gives us
which we must use i didn't say that
clearly let me say differently
the carnal nature cannot repent
paul said in romans 7 18 for i know that
in me that is in my flesh
dwelleth no good thing
and repentance
is a good thing are you with me you're a
little slow maybe that's my fault i'm
slow too
paul says that in my flesh dwelleth
no good thing repentance is a good thing
the carnal nature
cannot repent god has to give us
repentance
second timothy chapter 2 verse 24 25 and
of course
uh acts chapter 5 verse 31 to give
repentance to israel and forgiveness of
sins
and so god said the son of man has come
to seek
let's pause on seek this
meeting which will run until the 29th is
god
seeking somebody
you have to decide if that person is you
let me say again
this meeting is god seeking someone
and god may have been seeking you for
years
this morning's message was god seeking
someone
a billboard on a poster somewhere a wall
may be god's way of seeking a person you
turn on your car radio up comes the
sermon
that may be god's way of seeking you
you've got a friend who's a christian
it may be god's way of seeking you god
finds ways
to seek us why because he is not willing
finish my words that any should perish
the son of man has come to seek and to
save
that which was lost let me comment on
seek again
they have to follow in that order
what do i mean he has to seek you first
before he saves you you know why god has
to seek you
someone tell me why does god have to say
okay we're hiding true
that began with adam why does god have
to seek us
when adam sinned here's adam he sinned
on earth
here's god in heaven the problem has to
be solved who moved
god moved okay why does god have to seek
us
because we will not seek him
i need to say that again the carnal
nature
does not seek god now it may seek
church not god
did some people say crucify him in the
bible were they church members
oh yes the carnal nature has no problem
with church it has a problem
with god
and so god has to seek us and i'm saying
to someone listening to me wherever you
are
god is seeking you
let's go to first peter chapter 5.
first peter five our subject the man
and his mission thirteen minutes to
eight
do you have first peter five read verse
8 with me
be sober be vigilant come on
because your adversary the devil as a
roaring lion
walketh about seeking whom he may devour
now
what do you observe between first peter
5 8
and luke 19 10. what does luke 19 10 say
the son of man has come to seek and to
save what does first peter 5 8
say the devil like a roaring lion
walketh about seeking what do you notice
jesus seeks you come on and satan seeks
you
now yes you're one step ahead of me most
people are it's okay
the devil seeks you to destroy you
listen to what jesus does i am come that
they might have
life come on and that they might have it
more abundantly
the devil seeks you to destroy your life
but you can destroy your life by
fattening you up
the different ways to kill a person you
can kill immediately
or slowly the devil can give you things
of this world
and that way he kills you because he
draws you you see distance from god
is distance from life
and so in proverbs 8 36 the bible says
all they that hate me
love death distance from god is distance
from life
the devil walketh about seeking whom he
may devour
jesus seeks whom he might save no matter
this mission
christ came to tell sinners stop
i'll give you the power to stop smoking
i'll give you the power to stop stealing
i'll put in your heart a love for
spiritual things
you read matthew 9 9 to 10 to 13
i i'm not come to call the righteous but
sinister repentance
we read luke 19 10 the son of man has
come to seek and to save
that which was lost let's go to john 10
read verse 10. we already said it but
let's go there and read it now
john 10 10 our subject the man in his
mission let me pray again dear god
as we proceed continue to tell me what
to say and help me to listen
in jesus name i pray amen john 10 10.
do you have that read with me the thief
cometh not
but for to steal to kill and to destroy
stop
i don't care how much the devil has
given you his purpose
is to take your life if you're a farmer
and you want to sell a cow what do you
do to the cow first
you fatten it up
anything the devil gives you he is
threatening you
for the kill understand me clearly
understand the bible
the thief cometh not but for to steal
to kill and to destroy
i am come just christ come on tell me
why
that they might have life and that they
might have it more abundantly which
means
a life without christ is no life
in the eyes of god and we ought to live
through god's eyes a life without christ
is no life it's a living death as i told
you this morning 1st timothy
chapter 5 verse 6 she that liveth in
pleasure is
dead while she liveth
i am come that they might have life
as he said in john 15 without me
he can do nothing
christ came for the sinners to
repentance
christ came to seek and to
save christ came that they might have
life
and they might have it more abundantly
let's go to first john chapter three our
subject
the man and his mission
first john chapter three it's a very
powerful verse never forget this verse
memorize it and
use it against the enemy
towards the back of the bible find
revelation revelation jews second third
john ii john
first john you have that
since you're seeking so desperately for
first john let me ask you this question
how many of you can recite the bible in
order all 66 books can i say
all 66 books in order which one of you
you can you can
did you raise your hand come on
by the time you finish they'll still be
looking for first john chapter three so
you come
you come you know many years ago we were
called what
the people of the book nobody calls us
that now come my lovely sister don't be
afraid
you don't need a microphone genesis to
revelation
all right
hello
um
say amen god bless you sister god bless
you god bless you
i mean that from my heart god bless you
let me tell you something
when she says she knew it i believed her
getting up in front of people is
something else altogether
everything leaves your head and so god
bless you god bless you my lovely sister
god bless you
where did i send you first john chapter
verse 8 what's our subject the man in
this mission
read that verse with me microscopically
he that committed sin is of the devil
for the devil sinneth from the beginning
finish the verse now
for this purpose the son of god
was manifested that he might destroy
the works of the devil
story for you i'm not a big story person
but this is a testimony
i was in a certain country on the face
of the earth a few years ago preaching
young lady came to me i am bothered by
demons
every night they come they physically
molest me they do this they do that
she says i haven't slept in months
i told her step number one confess your
sins
sin is an embassy the devil occupies and
god respects that
you didn't hear what i said sin is the
devil's
embassy i don't mean a mistake i mean
the life of sin that's the devil's
embassy
and the only way god is coming in there
is if we call him are you following me
all right
i told a confessional says recommit your
life to god
one percent not 99.9
because then satan controls 0.01 are you
with me
100 give your life to god
then i gave her first john 3 he that
committed sinners of the devil
for the devil sinneth from the beginning
for
this purpose the son of god
was manifested sent that he might
destroy the works of the devil
i said tell god keep his word
remind god he's not willing to then he
should perish
are you following me remind god that
he's all powerful
and confront god respectfully with this
word
please father destroy what the devil is
doing in my life
i have now committed my life to you
she came back the next night to the
crusade
she said elder i slept for the first
time
in months somebody say man
in months someone wrote me
a text i'm bothered by spirits
they're all over my house around my
grounds and i gave them the word of god
here's why i gave the word of god go to
matthew 8 quickly then we'll come back
to first john 3
is 4 minutes to 8. matthew 8 reading
verse 16. we don't understand the power
of god's word
because we're too busy depending on
other things
the only thing satan respects is the
power of god's word
do you have matthew 8 verse 16 read with
me and when the even was come
they brought unto him what many that
possess with
and he cast out the spirits how with his
word
this now first john 3 8
christ came to destroy the works of the
devil
how does he do that how did he destroy
satan's work in the wilderness
it is written now
i don't know what the devil is doing in
your life
but he's doing something for somebody
the bible says one one
part of the mission of jesus was to
destroy
the works of the devil his work may be
sickness in your life
in luke 13 from verse 11 to 16 jesus met
a woman who was stooped over she could
not stand up straight
and in verse 16 he said uh not this
woman being a daughter of abraham
whom satan hath bound lord these 18
years be loosed from this bond on the
sabbath day
jesus said the devil had her in that
condition
did not the devil put sickness on job
the doubt now we
can we can cooperate by our health
practices but the devil
can put a disease on you
christ came to destroy the work the
devil can get into your house
and cause commotion in your family so
that the household is split
christ came to destroy the works of the
devil
the devil gets into a church
and splits it and both sides are
righteous
christ came come on to destroy
the works of the devil
and he does it through his word
what's our subject the man
and his mission the son of man has come
to seek
and to save
someone who is not in trouble doesn't
need to be saved
the fact that christ came to save means
the entire world
is in trouble and his mission is to save
he came not for the righteous but to
call sinners
to repentance god is the god of love
but here's how the bible is christ
christ and whatever christ is the father
is
hebrews 1 9 thou hast love righteousness
come on
and hated iniquity listen to me
carefully god
hates sin
if you think he loves you and he does
flip that coin
he hates sin
and so christ came to say stop
here's the power to stop turn from the
thing that's killing you
sin is always self-destructive and those
in the ambit of the sinner
are also affected sin is always
self-destructive for the sinner only
christ can deliver that person
and he came to call sinners to
repentance
if someone's listening to me there's
something you need to repent of make
that choice right now
you know salvation is not a difficult
thing there's one problem what's that
but yes but let's be nice and not say us
let's be right
there's one problem what's that there
starts with an s has an i then an
n how many clues do you need sin is the
problem
for how many cultures all cultures
one christ for all cultures one calvary
for all cultures you make too much of
culture
are you following me there's one culture
in this world that's sin
christ came to change it and introduced
what culture
the culture of heaven so he says in the
lord's prayer thy will be done on earth
as it is in heaven the culture of heaven
must be transferred to this earth
through the sacrifice of christ
the problem is sin the solution jesus
christ came to get us from the power of
sin
here's what the angel told jesus about
jesus joseph
in a vision or dream matthew 1 21
and thou shalt call his name jesus and
she shall bring forth a son
and thou shalt call his name why for he
shall
save his people from the sins but what
is the title of our message for this
evening
the man we've been looking at what the
mission
let's take a peek at the man if i do
that let me pray father
as i take a close look at your son my
savior one equal with yourself
instruct me i pray in the name of jesus
amen
read matthew 1 21 again carefully
do you have it and there's no text on
the screen at my request
so don't crucify the handsome men in
that booth back there
i want you to open your bibles i was at
a church service once this actually
happened
and people worshipping and singing and
the screen malfunction and the worship
stop
the singing stop now that's a disgrace
to god
i've never seen a bible malfunction come
on somebody say amen
i have seen phones malfunction i've
never seen one of these plugged in they
come fully powered from heaven somebody
say amen
i've never seen a bible malfunction
are you following me all right what book
did i tell you
matthew 1 let's read from verse 21 read
with me
and she shall bring forth a son and thou
shalt call his name jesus why for he
shall
save his people from these sins now who
is
it saving us from our sins is this able
this person truly able to deliver
because sin
is a tremendous power what did paul say
who shall deliver me from the body of
this death
whoo go to verse 23 of the same matthew
1.
let's add that to verse 21 and i want
you to tell me what you see
do you have verse 23 read with me what
does that say
behold a virgin shall be with child and
shall
bring forth a son and they shall call
his name which being interpreted
is now all right
what's his name in verse 21 what does
that mean
savior what's his name in verse 23
what does that mean god
then our savior is god
that amen needs prayer
week come on say amen your savior
is god i never said your savior is the
father
your savior is god
now here's what the bible says about god
go to luke 137
no one there's no excuse for sin
anyone who's lost is lost by choice
by the way those who are saved are saved
by choice whosoever believeth
or does not believe i said luke chapter
verse 37 do you have that now before we
read that verse let's review
matthew 1 21 says thou shalt call his
name
why for he shall save so he is presented
as
savior in verse 21. in verse 23 his name
is
emmanuel which being interpreted is god
with us so the savior is god
let's learn something about god verse 37
luke 1 read with me nice and loud
for with god come on nothing shall be
impossible including the situation
you're in right now
where is unemployment a problem with the
irs and they don't get bigger than that
a divorce about to happen someone
whatever your child has left
whatever with god finish it
nothing now you go to god you say father
that's what you said
and titus chapter 1 verse 2 which god
that cannot lie
numbers 23 19 god is not a man he should
lie
tell god you cannot lie here is my
situation
i need a job i'm about to be deported
change the hearts of those uh people who
have the power to say yes or no
here is my situation dear god
nothing's impossible for you help me
i have one more exam to get my degree
but i don't have tuition
help me
i made a mistake and i'm facing 10 years
thou shall call his name that's the man
for he shall that's the mission
who is the man who's the man
who is the man who is the man
who is the man god
i didn't say the father i said god
because jesus is god
he's divine as much as the father is you
don't believe me go to first timothy
chapter three
my words are weak the bible's words are
powerful oh six after eight i need to
keep my word if i can if i don't
i'm a sinner first timothy chapter three
but i am but god has forgiven me i am
thankful for that so i'm willing to die
for him
first timothy 3 4 16 do you have that
come on come on come on come on
you're vegetarians move quickly all
right first timothy 3 13 what does the
bible say
say it with me and without controversy
great
is the mystery of godliness come on read
god was
manifest in the flesh stop
who showed up in the flesh god
go to isaiah nine
what's your subject the man in his
mission what's his mission
and who's the man god that's no joke
god because only god can handle satan
you didn't hear what i said it's my
fault anyway isaiah 9 i may come back to
that isaiah 9
6. are you with me if you have the king
james read with me
for unto us a child is born unto us
a son is given and the government shall
be upon his shoulder
and his name shall be called wonderful
come on counselor come on
the mighty god
the everlasting father that doesn't make
him the father it means he's the father
of everlastingness
put differently eternity flows from
jesus
he is the mighty god
now you read with god
nothing shall be impossible
let's say a woman is past child-bearing
age can she have a child normally
no those days are gone go to genesis 18.
genesis 18 it's 8 after 8 i will go past
8 15. if i go past please forgive me
ahead of time
all right god bless you for being nice
people genesis 18
what verse did i say 14. now god is
talking to abraham
now sarah has already laughed because
she heard god told abraham that she'd
have a son
because she had passed that age listen
to god's question to abraham in verse 14
of genesis 18 read it for me
is anything too hard for the lord stop
all right give me the answer
all right name some problems people have
come on tell me quickly what's that
sickness
is sickness too hard for the lord
another problem
what
financial problems is that too hard for
god no
give me a moral problem financial
difficulties not a moral problem give me
a moral problem
lying can god straighten out a liar yes
why because nothing is too hard for god
if you are listening i'm telling you
bring your situation
to christ he is god
that's why he came don't withhold your
problem from christ
and therefore put him out of work in
your life
bring it to him
matthew 11 28 come unto me
all ye that labor and a heavy lady
someone listening to me is heavy laden
we're very good at masking or putting
nice expressions
but god sees right through that come
unto me
jesus says you're carrying a tremendous
burden you can't carry it
give it to me all the that labor
what is all male female white black
rich poor educated and educated tall
short
come now we read that god can't lie am i
right
listen to these words i will give you
rest spoken by someone
who is both man and god and cannot lie
what's our subject who is that
what's the mission safe
[Music]
christ wants to do that for you whatever
your difficulty if you're listening
in a prison cell christ wants to save
you he may not bring you out of the cell
but he'll save your life because when he
saved the thief on the cross
he left him on the cross
a lot of people say lord save me and get
me out of no no no you stole you need to
pay back
are you following me he left him on the
cross but he'll be in the kingdom
that's what counts
if in the prison cell the lord can save
you in that cell
but you'll stain the cell he can bring
you out but he may not
how many of you will say lord i place my
burden
at your feet because i have one can i
see your hair
i've got a burden i place it at you all
people of all ages have burdens
children have their own burden they look
insignificant to us but they have
and the elderly have the middle age have
if you're watching online
put your burden at the feet of jesus
that's why he came
and watch him work and do what you
cannot do
and as he works in your life you will
have reason to say
god is good who is the man
what's his mission to save
wherever you are make a decision to let
christ direct your life
let christ start the process of changing
your life
you will be glad you did let someone in
your church know the pastor your head
elder
that you've made this decision you want
to walk with god
and i need walk with god you can see me
and so you perhaps may modify your
behavior god is as present as i am
you want to walk with him that he may
bless your life
make that decision don't worry about how
will i walk just
make the decision a decision is a
powerful thing just decide
i want to be baptized don't worry about
where what will i wear who will attend
just make a decision
that's all i want to stop what i'm doing
i want to be baptized i want to join the
church i want to go back to my family i
want to start supporting my children
i want to start doing better in school
just make a decision
that's all and leave the rest to god
and renew that decision has bowed eyes
closed father in heaven
we thank you for your word we thank you
that god our savior is
man and god as man he understands
temptation
as god he can strengthen us to resist as
man he
suffered pain and suffering their god as
god he can deliver us
as man he fought with the enemy and won
as god he empowers us to win
father jesus not only understands us
he can do something for us we come to
you now
father to place our burdens at your feet
and the heaviest burden we can carry
is sin we lay on our sins and we ask you
lord take us
fill us make us entirely yours
so that the devil has no right to our
lives make
us entirely yours as we leave this
building
even though the sun has set and the holy
day has passed the sun does not set on
our holiness
go with us watch over us tonight bring
us back tomorrow to hear your word again
i pray in jesus name let god's people
say
amen and amen